a California man is shot and killed by
police after he attempts to break into
an apartment where a woman and her child
were barricaded inside
it happened on October 30th in Santa
Maria California at about 10 30 that
evening a suspect later identified as 36
year old Salvador macido pulled multiple
knives on an officer six nine when I
come playing we're gonna be at the near
trash cans
as the officer on the scene called for
backup Messina backed off but when more
officers arrived they called for maceda
to drop the weapon more than 20 times
when he took several steps toward them
officers fired a beanbag round that hit
messida near his stomach
[Music]
that's when mesita throws a weapon at
officers nearly hitting them and a
nearby squad car after that he runs to a
nearby apartment building and hides
behind a wall 9-1-1 what's the address
of your emergency
731 Southwestern Avenue apartment and I
have my house surrounded by police
inside the apartment a woman and her
child barricade themselves and call
police you need to stay sheltered in
place we have someone that's up against
the wall there and you need to stay
inside
I am I'm in my bathroom and I have a gun
registered to me so if this guy okay
okay do you have all your doors and
windows locked yes for more than 90
minutes police and a hostage negotiators
speak with mesita asking him to set down
his knife meantime officers deploy a
drone to keep tabs on Messina at one
point drone video catches him setting
the knife down
it's them that officers fire pepper
rounds at mesita drone video then
catches mesita throw objects over the
balcony including a bike
thank you
after that mesita grabs the knife again
and attempts to break into the apartment
where the woman and her child are hiding
by opening the door and smashing a
window it's then that Santa Maria
officer Eric Kesh opens fire
officers on scene escort the woman and
her child out of the apartment
First Responders attempt to give mesita
medical attention but he died as a
result of his injuries later
investigations determined he was on
probation following an arrest for an
extended standoff in December 2021 when
he threw glass bottles at officers
Officer Hesh was initially placed on
administrative leave after the shooting
but has since returned to work right now
the shooting is under investigation by
the Santa Barbara sheriff's office after
that it will be sent to the Santa
Barbara County District Attorney's
office to determine whether the shooting
was justified for the latest
developments in this case an all things
True Crime stay with long crime Network
I'm Sierra Gillespie hey guys Sean
sticks Larkin here from on Patrol live
the holiday Season's Upon Us and if
you're looking for that perfect gift to
stuff down in that stocking or put under
the tree for somebody else pick up my
look breaking blue real life stories of
cops falsely accused it's a great read
something you don't want to miss you can
pick it up on Amazon